the weather is really in your face in
new orleans
it is a character in the play of new
orleans
this instrument the weather warlock is a
an audio mirror of the sunrise and
sunset so theoretically a blind person
could experience the sunrise and sunset
through audio in real time
my name is quintron it's not my real
name it's a given musician's name i
definitely consider myself first and
foremost to be a musician but i'm also a
builder and inventor of electronic
musical instruments and the device that
we're talking about today is called the
weather warlock which is a weather
controlled analog synth
right now we're hearing the sun just
start to activate the uv sensors
on the
outdoor sensor unit
that puttering sound is the sound of
that sensor just starting to get enough
light to
sonically activate it
it's using the weather to create music
there's no microphones there's no it's
not the sound of rain
there are two components an inside set
of brains which is the synthesizer part
and an outdoor set of sensors
there is a temperature sensor which is
affecting the speed of the drone
this drone
there is a set of wind
speed controlled sensors
the faster the wind blows the faster
they activate these two notes there is a
moisture sensor or rain or humidity or
snow the last one would be the sky
sensor which is a sensor at the top and
a little periscope that's aiming at the
sky
so you can play it like an instrument
too you can just let it do its thing but
i can also you know change the timber of
the drone
so sunrise is officially over
according to the weather warlock
and everyone else
check one two good evening you are tuned
in to weather for the blind dot o r g
broadcasting
as usual out of new orleans louisiana
the weather warlock has become a live 24
7
online musical feed
sunrise was at 5 15 this morning and
sunset
happening now as you can hear
according to our uv sensors
this hasn't made me see a sunset
differently
you can just hear it now
you